hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a brand new cry of fear
custom story called isolation I've been
looking for mostly because I really like
right I mean I really there's a fun
gaming this is incredibly well made mod
I mean it's it's incredible to know that
a free to play mod is able to do all
this
a community like this hi I don't know oh
I know you did
I'm a party animal a damn good question
Hosanna Linda thank you Wow laying
around the ballet
and by the way if you haven't noticed I
got my new professional Studio
Headphones kind of match my professional
microphones not really professional like
from it's a blue Yeti but well no I woke
up in a barn and ice woo hello and I
seem to be on a farm of some sort all
right
OOP half I go up here
hello here OOP there we go now everyone
knows that good things happen on farms
it's full of luck and vim and vigor and
that I must be used
I must be a giant look at this I can
stand right up I am way um kliklak
got it case you didn't catch it the name
of this one is called the isolation why
not just staining it like that oh it's
on a log weird that this is here ah ah
her was the last one that I played man
it's been a while
I remember when I move none of that now
it's too early to start that oh now I
just remembered when I first started
playing chainsaw man came with whistling
through the woods oh this looks normal
for a farm oh hey no whoa yeah [ __ ] off
me get it off me ah lunch Oh bones
ouch pounds yeah into pouch pouch first
but I thought now used to is your hug
ah what hi Oh
what was that now say one huh okay there
we go
running off to safety I hope
yeah
I really like that the community can
unleash their creativity I see you over
there don't think I don't see you
Oh Julian oh hello I've got a doubt
nope oh I got a catch oh no oh ho oh uh
wall but that invisible wall yeah each
other that's exactly what I want to
happen oh yeah each other up nice
uppercut to Noah yeah ha ha I should die
jeez Oh God oh hello Oh a knife I wish I
got that soon well that would have made
things a little bit easier now wouldn't
whoa oh it's big man hey hello oh
alright
do is that close I'm just gonna avoid
him I don't need to kill him as far as I
know I think I could just whoa oh god
it's one of you ladies geez no oh [ __ ]
no [ __ ] oh I'm the big guy
Oh guys guys die psych I've got a
problem up here oh my god Becca I think
he can one-shot me I'm not exactly sure
she screams weird looks weird I mean
even I wouldn't hit on her the hook that
would be nice if I had a pistol so
please can you give me a pistol before
this big guy uh don't let this be a dead
end
lady did you see it's stuck there do you
have a problem ha ha ha ha no aah
I'm one hit away from being dead oh that
looks normal one thing that's really
great about cry fear is the fact that
atmosphere is so pervasive I mean
there's all these weird noises music
fits together perfectly ambient sounds
and it's like oh it's combined into a
really really really atmospheric game
that's fantastic I've tried most of
these doors to no avail but
this one
they build the inside there if I can't
get in so I've always liked teams I
color for what they've done here to
dedicate yourself to making a game like
this
come on I mean obviously this custom
story wasn't made by them ah here we go
to making a free game like this whoa
what the heck
hello oh good I was wondering when
reality was about to unravel I'm glad
that that's happening now Oh what's with
this floating box all right this is a
bad idea going in here ahh the heck is
that what is that what is what is that I
don't even know what oh hello okay oh my
oh hello
okay now um I already have a knife thank
you
Wow are those eyeballs those are
eyeballs aren't they
then yep this is where the mind shatters
and all reality oh boy I'm not gonna
make this one having saved it like
forever
oh thank you God God I hadn't seen that
I would have died been doomed forever my
goodness
let's see how much I fail horribly a lot
haha
cirno says a lot wrong with me school
nightmare
actually I landed on then I backed
trying to recalibrate by backing up but
then I overcompensated good yeah Hank
whoa all right then but oh oh this is
good without oh come on oh my god those
mates a job well we're gonna be here
awhile ladies and gentleman so I hope
you
up
Oh
Oh ow ow ah God
learning this garnet got the morphine
syringe okay
here we go nope oh right off the bat as
peruse I get worse as I progress god
damn it
I'm so bad at jumping puzzles I hate
them if anybody remembers the jumping
puzzle from the original cry of fear
you'll you have front you have a good
memory but that's beside I mean now
seriously how am I supposed to and maybe
I'm not supposed to be able to jump
maybe I'm just supposed to run okay
that's it
much nicer hello Geronimo Oh ready then
yeah Oh that letter that looks normal
thanks Joe Fang lots of bullets you
lighten your actually wait a minute what
not third third oh oh
come for a showdown like I just need my
pistol in this one I don't bring it
that's right
oh yeah I remember now you know the back
eyeball that thing that everybody has
come up ouch miss Mei Bao
oh my gosh right like a mouse
oh no I hope I don't fail whoa no anyway
get away going good I pull down you
douche
I know I know there we go there we go
all right I should have enough ammo to
take terrible Oh Oh what end of the demo
man the only thing that I'm disappointed
in these particular custom campaigns for
cry fears that they're so short I mean
obviously because I'm in the game and
there is no score system I can't exactly
pick out which one better than the other
so I'm kind of just going down the list
I mean for one it's really cool that you
know the atmosphere is there and all
that but you know I really would like
some more length to these games I mean I
there's so much potential for creativity
and if any of you guys know if I've
already played her now isolation out of
it and I think I think memories and I
don't know if I did the community I did
the Community Club yes I did so any of
these other ones you know that's better
than this one or better than any of the
others and I you think I should play
first then let me know in the comments
below other than that that was a good
one so far just really really short and
even if I ate up some time failing there
at the jumping puzzles so anyway I hope
you all enjoyed it thanks for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always we'll see
you in the next video bye-bye